un meurtre d'une particulière brutalité
c'est dans un immeuble du centre ville
de Tours que les policiers ont fait ce
mardi soir l'effroyable découvert un
corps inanimé celui d'une femme d'une
vingtaine d'années larguée pardon d'une
quinzaine de coups de couteau un suspect
a été interpellé son père placé en garde
à vue Faustine une
c'est dans l'un de ces immeubles de la
rue Voltaire situé derrière moi que ce
sont produits les faits mardi soir selon
une source policière c'est une voisine
qui aurait alerté les forces de l'ordre
la brigade de nuit est donc intervenue
vers 21h30 pour tenter de mettre fin à
cette scène de violence une opération
très délicate selon la police qui a pu
interpeller une personne sur place un
homme il s'agirait du père de la jeune
fille décédée
âgé de 22 ans la victime est
probablement morte de ses blessures
après avoir reçu une quinzaine de coups
de couteau de son assaillant la
procureur de Tours précise que le
suspect était placé en garde à vue et
qu'une enquête est en cours pour tenter
de déterminer les circonstances du drame